hello the Internet my name's Gavin I'm
Dan we're the slow mo guys something I
quite like the look on Dan in slow mo is
bullets coming out of a gun hitting
stuff yeah very fast though very fast
plus gab scared of guns hate them so
instead I had to buy a little ol piece
still okay remember we did the assault
right for you all for like this leading
back closing right so a little air
pistol yep
slightly safer option yeah we're gonna
shoot some deodorant sticks different
colors not sponsored by Old Spice no
couldn't buy off-brand ones you had to
go for Old Spice oh look I was in a rush
you may think why a stick of deodorant
and I'll tell you they're sort of good
at showing an entrance and exit wound
their goopy but after the damage is done
they hold their form so you see that the
flowering right now so they're less
they're not as strong as flesh but we're
also using a air pistol so it's like
yeah balancing outlet it's really not a
good test of anything but it might I
might look look erase they've justify it
might look good in slow-mo let's do it
you're gonna be using the V 25 11
insanely fast camera will start at
28,000 frames a second because once
again we filmed it on the phantom flex
it be a couple of blurs yeah couple bow
frames we get the blue shoot through it
start with a book safety off
plip hey defense all right we'll have
that coming slightly offset straight
through here yeah yeah just don't shoot
the lens hole I'll try not to
yeah flip and wish it
[Music]
if you've ever accidentally shot through
some deodorant yeah what you can do is
just push the stick up enough so that
the bullet hole is gone and then you can
just cut with a knife yeah the top part
that is a pro tip also aka we only
bought one and now we're screwed
yeah so we've got two shots and that's
it yeah so nothing goes to waste and
slower guys we get everything high
budget videos fun back to shopping this
for this video a deodorant yeah maybe a
future buyer by a few alright I'm fine
more than one I've got it I've got it
it's very nice Oh deluxe look at that oh
you thought you'd never noticed yeah so
that last one was wicked so I've lowered
the resolution now we're now a hundred
and twenty thousand frames a second I'll
just close in on that exit wound exactly
the same exactly the same okay I'm gonna
place it down oh oh it's a bit tricky
because it's so top-heavy now it's gonna
fall over
that's alright as long as it falls after
the event we have to do it the other way
have to flop it okay son in that Oh
it's pretty ugly shooting against direct
sunlight but now these speeds who gives
it it's a must here we go oh that
destroyed the whole thing of it
absolutely chop the top off there made a
perfect little canyon through that oh
yeah
it must have sent some bits flying cuz I
saw just when I got hit in the neck with
a little bit of it I hope you alright
my necks gonna be smelling like Terry
Crews I met Terry yes yeah I saw him one
did in 2007 I'll be at the premiere of
it was like balls of fire or something
was like a table tennis movie and it
where is it that individually we've both
met Terry Crews but nine years apart
well I haven't met him I was like
alright tether just sort of Sauron was
like oh damn it's Terry Crews you still
have the picture you took of it yeah
okay it's a tall order be but could you
get it to go in from its really entire
thing from left to right but fever the
front edge so it's just barely in the
front or do you think I'm close okay
alright I don't even know why sorry
nailed it oh man just dug out the front
nailed it look at that and it's good for
another exit wound shot
actually looks like it's rightfully not
sure whether it's the sheen on the Sun
or whether it's actually spinning I know
it's definitely spinning yeah even these
little pistols have mercury is that true
I guess it makes sense why not right
found a second blue one then yep
absolutely okay so I think for grand
finale will line up all the ones we
didn't use
that's what sixth oh yes and try and
shoot down the line of all of them okay
what do you thinks gonna happen though I
think what if three things will happen
it will blast through all of them yeah
it will get lodged in one of them or it
will enter and exit before it gets to
the end
so my ex a number four or something yeah
how many do you think you'll get through
then if you if it's gonna stop in one of
them it's gonna stop I'd say the last
one because I'm pretty sure it's gonna
go through every single I think it's
pretty warm today so this is all day
quite soft it's not the best-looking
framing because the the table is on the
piss but uh anyway I'm gonna correct it
with a camera there you go okay
[Music]
I am in the face Oh Oh what much is it
large it's not they actually stop yeah
only got through one tooth it got
through Easter them the fourth one you
can see it look look at that perfectly
in the middle of the boat oh no put up
to the light
hold on to the Sun oh you fully see it
in there literally perfectly suspended
yeah
that's incredible isn't it so basically
I just keep that yeah that's a trophy
although one day Oh use it and be like
oh I've got ball bearing in my armpit oh
wow we stopped a bullet well we stopped
an air pistol bullet with with just
deodorant well you were right with one
of the options so that must mean the
third one is the most well the least
damage well yeah because it's come up
perfectly through the year through your
hole there I can't see through it but oh
you see on oh well there you go can't
miss it
no but look at this though it absolutely
tore through the flu ones I think the
blue ones are softer well they're also
pre wounded
yeah the pre wounded but I think they're
also like more susceptible to heat
because this one's much more solid yeah
and then it couldn't even get through
the last green one so very cool you can
trace the path of it through the green
ones if you hold this up here that's the
part it took yeah very neat
lovely yeah I mean you can see what you
meant by the whole flesh winds thing
yeah it's the one with the it's fully
lodged in number four there that's cool
I love it some very low resolution
footage there but it does show in more
detail what's happening yeah we needed
to see detail not resolution detail
basically the cameras great for making
gifts because they're a bow that size
yeah hopefully you enjoyed that video
feel free to follow us on Twitter
subscribe to our second channel and buy
so much nice and match my summation nice
and I will hopefully see you in the next
video
absolutely